barbers with us in California hey
Barbara welcome to Dave Ramsey chef
thank you for taking my call
I've been trying to get in for weeks
glad you got in how can we help well I
know what needs to be done but I don't
know how to do it
my fiancé has co-signed for two loans
for his daughter and we recently found
out that she's been very inconsistent in
making payments we know they should be
sold but they're not being cooperative
they're in their late 30s early 40s and
say well if your money is none of your
business our money what you know
everything is not anybody else's
business but we don't know you know at
this how do you do this with adult kids
know how old your daughter these are
these are this is his daughters she's 37
one is a one of the vehicles is a car
that's about $15,000 upside down the
other is a luxury RV and how long ago
did your fiancee sign for these the RV
was four years ago
the car was two years ago okay and then
he met you and you set him straight
oh I've known him for 20 plus years but
he just he always trusted that she said
she was paying it and on time and he was
never concerned with his credit score or
his credit report and never checked they
shared a peel box so then when you
immediately never got mail
yeah because we're working on our first
budget together and honor you to be
married well we are down to this Sunday
Wow going on since thank you well you're
marrying in a marry into the soup
okay right yeah and your fiance has
raised a princess he's been he's never
told her she no for anything and now
you've come in and started saying no
you're gonna be the Wicked Witch of them
West this the ugly stepmother hmm if
you're not real careful hold on through
the break I want John to talk to you
about this we're talking with Barbara in
California is getting ready to get
married Sunday to a fiance who has a 34
year old daughter he co-signed an
expensive RV and co-signed a car she's
not paying the bills and so his credits
getting dinged the mother the stepmother
to be discovered all of this and his
suggesting that it's a bad idea of
course it's a bad idea
what can she do about it John Barbara's
a son right yeah yeah so here's a couple
of things one it's his job his number
one job in this deal is to love his
daughter and so I'm gonna challenge you
with doing the best you can to not talk
bad about his daughter and make him
choose sides because his the side he's
got to choose is with her the second
thing is is he really has two options
number one he can sue his daughter or he
can pay the bills we call it a stupid
tax around here or maybe a princess tax
or pay the bill and one thing that
drives me crazy with adults is when they
want to have one side of the of the
scale but not the other right so I'm
gonna take your money I want you to
co-sign and then they get indignant and
say you can't ask questions about my
money you don't get to talk about money
absolutely he does and so I'd recommend
that he have a non-emotional go for
coffee go for a restaurant that might be
open in California there and sit down
and talk to his daughter about hey we
got to come to terms deal right all
right and you don't go and we got to
have yeah you don't go that's job and
you don't say a word about this and then
after you get married you build a budget
together and you go forward and you may
have to build in a deluxe RV payment
that you're not kidding to something you
need you do need agreement from your
friend so he never does this again
that's right going forward but if you
say a word it'll undo everything all you
can do is encourage him to have a
backbone with her because for some
reason or another he's not in the past
and Christmas love her be
kind yes I knew stay out of it because
you're not gonna you're not going to
cause anything good to happen she you
know and she's going to view this whole
change in attitude you're them as your
fault that's right and so you got to
stay way back from that